quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
are you being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you
tails okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment
for you to show us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved but some part of you knew that
was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
the most important choice in neil's life
it's my turn to believe in her
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
[Applause]
if you want to see twitter again
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
family movie night is getting revamped
only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human dread dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i literally never
seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stir stereo man
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
i'm the greatest photographer that life
magazine has ever had i'm tired
my body's older than i am
and who broke
you're the single most impossible
photographer that life has ever had well
if you say that then
there's a company that's dumping toxic
waste into the sea
people dying
the cover-up
is as much of a story as the story
itself
for 15 years they knew
and they kept poisoning people
there's a resistance on the ground we
are not so easy to keep quiet
we need global attention with you we
have a better chance i'm here to help if
i can but i need you to help me
mr smith would you like something to
drink i'd rather wait until i get
outside the building before i drop dead
what what is happening here play out
here
where it belongs
it's been made very clear to me now
and i am seriously unwelcome here
[Music]
listen to me i need the pictures gene
[Music]
we're gonna do this together
[Music]
pick up your camera
point
focus
click
that's how you tell your story
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
communicable
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you are leaving us maurice yourself
where am i going
to a lavish and glimmering hell
i'd always have the tails of versailles
and stuff of dreams
[Music]
you're something they can never be
an individual
this place is so beautiful
[Music]
creature in the water you should not be
swimming in there
she called me
is certainly not of this world nor am i
the creature will be killed placing the
life force into our hands this is murder
she is your pet she's all but human
the mermaid
[Music]
do you believe in coincidence
[Music]
[Music]
all right june can you tell me what this
is
it's
uh
the best place for you to be right now
is right here with us
fun friday
daisy
[Music]
we're not a bad bunch
we're not doing a runner here are we
[Music]
thank god hello pet you know how i am i
sure do you sold my house where did you
get those clothes actually we should
probably get off their property
i do need to get hold of that son of
mine is he at work is he we divorced
three years ago
no what happened to architecture what is
this a photocopy shock
we also scan and print
this lucidity you're experiencing
will be temporary you've come back at a
tricky pace i think i've come back just
in time this is why businesses slow down
neither of you knows how to stick at one
thing can't you just act like a normal
mother for five minutes i have really
missed you you know
dearest ginny i've gone to get my
dresser back
p.s i'm borrowing your car
this is breaking an interview
what is it about the dresser it was the
one piece of him that i kept
[Music]
all that control that you seem to think
that you have over this company you
don't
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
what's that
power up you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons a
billionaire arms dealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star greg simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's none of you you made that quite
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nervous
they're all the killers
you're an actor
act
okay
i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesca what's
next for dude i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe do whatever i do
whatever i do do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night dear friends
can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
they're going to kill you now shoot him
first then
tidy
what happens you recognize your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name cover's
blown we're burnt what do i do the emoji
style is gonna melt
[Music]
you stop danny francesca you stopped
then
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes do you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone
yes
james bakery yeah dea military
yeah i tell you i'm very impressed
hey
it's nice to have you home i feel much
better now
i found something in my room you found
all of that money we have to tell mom
and dad you don't know who this money
belongs to
i heard you were getting out today
oh jesus
let's go we got some business to take
care of
three million where is it our old house
put one hand on my daughters now make
sure you die you're just gonna have to
kill me then boy what are we gonna do
don't worry i'm built for this
enough with the kids sweetheart
you gotta go
i didn't know you could play the piano
well there's a lot about me you don't
know
[Music]
sarah sometimes the voices in our head
are there to guide us
it's okay
[Music]
everything's
hello
are you there
everything is going to be different now
you saw it for yourself
there was no one there sarah
the third floor is off limits
[Music]
i need you
[Music]
how long have i been here
a year
helen tell it detective shepard since
you're the only witness of this suicide
what was your relationship like with
your father we were close
he said something to me the night i need
to remember if you can tell me anything
sometimes these things are best
put to rest
did you ever see or hear
anything weird
first it was the little things
i thought was my imagination
i think no revenants our souls have come
against heaven
they have targeted you
do you remember anything about the
people that lived here before my dad
what's all this about the disappearances
of kids all i ever got sackhead took him
sackhead
i've always suspected that whoever
killed these kids has
my father
what was he hiding
the less you know
the
oh my better
[Music]
you know that plane was down behind
enemy lines
and we're carrying
sensitive material
this don't make sense we've been
following this contour for an hour
now we're in the same spot
[Music]
what the
did our guys do it no way
this operation has been designated top
secret
i heard stories about nazi doctors doing
this kind of thing it wasn't the
[Music]
when
germans
entered the land of the dead
the demons they changed the stars so he
would lose direction
i want a better explanation
i imagine we're going to find out soon
you put down that gun buddy
only one problem with that i like it
here
[Music]
oh no
dear god
i'm going to get my boots a little dirty
[Music]
we found the plane can we go home now
[Music]
you knew we were never going home
[Music]
[Music]
you